Speaker 1: You all know that I am in general
a pragmatist. I am a sort of realpolitik
realist. I understand that change often comes
in small steps. I don't want to let the perfect
become the enemy of the good. But it may
be time for progressives to kill what is
increasingly a gutted infrastructure and spending
bill because there is almost nothing left in it.
Paid leave has now fallen out of the democratic
package in an urgent scramble, as described by CNN
to secure centrist Democratic Senator Joe Manchin
support. Democrats are expected to scrap paid
family and medical leave from their cornerstone
economic and climate package, discarding one of
the central planks of Joe Biden's proposal as they
scramble to strike a deal with holdout senators.
The plan's survival has been in question for
several days due to objections from Joe Manchin.
Biden's initial 12 week proposal of paid leave
was scaled back to four weeks to try to get
Joe Manchin support that was rejected. Kirsten
Gillibrand tried to find a compromise with margin
that didn't work. One of the people said,
prompting Democrats to push it out of the package
as they seek to scale back the proposals overall
cost and programs to meet mansion's demand.
Manchin made clear he would not move when
asked about the provision, saying I just
can't do it. And now, as we're filming, this
is about to happen. Joe Biden is expected
to announce new social spending and new social
spending framework to try to get every Democrat
on board. The steps that we are now talking about,
the increments that we are now talking about
are so small in terms of what's left of this
bill that we may mostly have a pseudo slush fund
for some projects called infrastructure. It'll
be counted as a political win for the centrist
Democrats. It'll be counted as a political win for
Republicans by having been able to get all sorts
of stuff removed. And it's going to be barely
anything, and I am essentially ready to say,
you know, it has some things in it that
makes sense. But the big picture is now
so dire. It's so grim. It's so pathetic that
it may be time to kill this bill and say, Hey,
you need us progressives for this too, and
you're losing us. What has been removed so
far? My best under you? It's actually hard to
encapsulate everything that's been removed so far
for a bunch of different reasons, including that
there were different bills that contain these
things in different negotiations. Paid family
leave seems to be gone or will be gone soon.
A tuition free community college. We already
learned days ago last week that's gone.
A serious climate regulations gone. Expanded
Medicare eligibility gun. The vision hearing
dental stuff that Joe Biden talked about doesn't
seem to be in their prescription drug price
controls. Nope. Universal child care plus making
permanent the tax credit gone. Some kind of tax
to target the very, very, very richest Americans
now that are not going to be part of this bill,
apparently, either. So listen, I get it. This is
very rare that I say actually overall because of
a message that needs to be sent. Nothing kind of
makes more sense than the scraps that are left.
Rarely am I at that point. People who have been
following the show for a long time know that,
but it might be time with this bill because this
is going to. It'll count as something was done
when it's two percent, five percent, not by
dollar value, but in terms of the components.
Five percent of what it was supposed to be
done. And everybody but the left gets a win.
Republicans who want nothing done well, they
almost get a win if this passes because there's
almost nothing left of it. Centrists get what
they want because they've managed to get all
of the important stuff or most of the important
stuff out of it or scale it down or whatever. So
I am understanding, you know, I know other shows
pretend that the country is way more left than
it actually is. And all this different stuff. I
don't do that here. I feel like one of the things
I try to do is give you an honest and accurate
assessment of where is the country on a lot of
these issues. The country is well to the left
of this bill. There is no doubt about it. And
what we have at this point is I don't know if the
term pyrrhic victory even applies because I don't
know that it's a victory, even a pyrrhic one.
I want to hear from you. Is this something that
any progressive that has the ability to vote no
should be voting no on because it's become so
endlessly pathetic? Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We're going to take a quick break, and
we have much more coming up for you today